From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。
Public Radio--
公共广播——
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
国际广播电台。
--Radio International.
——国际广播电台。
One more time.
再来一次。
It's not enough, some guys say, to have the right boots and the right 19th century authenticated gun and the right uniform made from the right fabric with the right buttons and no zippers, of course, because they had no zippers back during the Civil War. No, it is not enough.
有些人说，仅仅有合适的靴子、经过认证的19世纪枪支、用正确布料制作且没有拉链的制服（当然，内战时期没有拉链）是不够的。不，这还远远不够。
But what is enough? Some guys come to Civil War reenactments and bring sodas and coolers and Band-Aids. There are guys who wear wristwatches and contact lenses. The thing about recreating the Civil War is that everyone draws the line somewhere else.
但什么才算够呢？有些人参加内战重演时会带上汽水、冷藏箱和创可贴。还有人戴着手表和隐形眼镜。重现内战的难点在于，每个人的底线都不一样。
It's better if I walk in than if I drive in.
我走进去比开车进去更好。
I don't wear no underwear.
我不穿内衣。
I don't carry pears or bananas or anything like that. Where are they going to get bananas during the Civil War?
我不带梨、香蕉或其他类似的东西。在内战时期他们去哪儿弄香蕉？
I eat raw meat.
我吃生肉。
We have people here who believe that their impression's more authentic than somebody else's because they have fleas.
这里有些人认为，因为他们身上有跳蚤，所以他们的表演比别人更真实。
A Chinese man came to me and wanted to join the unit. There were no Chinese in the 100th. My unit, I would prefer to have just plain old Caucasian males.
有个华人想加入我们的连队。第100连里没有华人。至于我的连队，我更倾向于只要纯粹的白人男性。
This tape is from a documentary by Jessica Yu called Men of Reenaction. And she found out that when men stage Civil War reenactments, sure, there is some tension between the Union and the Confederate forces. But the real battle is the one within the ranks over who is properly authentic and who is not. And like any conflict that's big enough and important enough to people, this conflict has spawned its own vocabulary. The guys who do these reenactments call themselves either hard-cores or farbs. You can guess what the hard-cores are. Those are the guys who really want to be authentic. Farbs, well, farb is short for far be it from me, as in "far be it from me to judge what that person is doing right over there."
这段录音来自杰西卡·余（Jessica Yu）拍摄的纪录片《重演者》（Men of Reenaction）。她发现，当男人们策划内战重演时，联邦军和联盟军之间确实存在一些紧张关系。但真正的战斗发生在队伍内部，关于谁才是真正的“正统”，谁不是。像任何对人们来说足够大、足够重要的冲突一样，这场冲突也催生了自己的词汇。参加这些重演的人自称为“硬核”（hard-cores）或“法布”（farbs）。你可以猜到“硬核”是什么意思。这些人是真正想要追求真实的人。“法布”嘛，“farb”是“far be it from me”（“我可不敢评判……”）的缩写，意思是“我可不敢评判那个人在那儿做什么”。
A farb? A farb is someone who is not as authentic as you think of yourself. That's the easiest way I put it. A farb is anyone who would wear tennis shoes or would wear modern eye glasses or would wear cotton instead of wool. When I see someone in line and he's got modern glasses, that takes away from my event. It might not affect his event, but it takes away from mine.
法布？法布是指那些不像你认为自己那么真实的人。这是我能给出的最简单的说法。任何穿网球鞋、戴现代眼镜或穿棉布而不是羊毛衣服的人都是法布。当我在队列中看到有人戴着现代眼镜时，这破坏了我的体验。它可能不影响他的体验，但确实破坏了我的。
I'm in this for fun. I'm not really in the Army. And so if I want to have an ice chest hidden in a wooden box that only I know is there, then I will do that. I draw the line at what the public sees and perceives.
我参加这个是为了好玩。我又不是真的在军队里。所以，如果我想在一个只有我知道的木箱里藏一个冰盒，那我就这么做。我的底线是公众所看到和感知到的范围。
You know, it is hard to imagine people in other countries-- English and French citizens reenacting the Norman conquest or North and South Vietnamese recreating their bloody civil war. The question here is why do Americans devote so much emotional energy to restaging the past?
你知道，很难想象其他国家的人——英国和法国公民重演诺曼征服，或者南越和北越人重演他们血腥的内战。这里的问题是，为什么美国人投入如此多的情感能量来重现过去？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, and invite various writers, performers, documentary producers to take a whack at that theme. Our program today, Simulated Worlds. We visit wax museums, simulated coal mines, fake ethnic restaurants, an ersatz Medieval castle, and other recreated worlds that thrive all across our great land.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各类作家、表演者和纪录片制作人对该主题进行探讨。我们今天的节目是《模拟世界》。我们将参观蜡像馆、模拟煤矿、虚假的民族餐厅、人造中世纪城堡，以及我们这片伟大土地上蓬勃发展的其他再造世界。
The Italian writer Umberto Eco wrote an essay a few years ago in which he argued that this urge to create miniature simulated worlds is a particularly American impulse, a significant American aesthetic and one that is not talked about very often. Eco traveled the United States from Disneyland to Las Vegas to re-creations of old New York in museums. After a visit to the LBJ Library in Austin, Texas, where he saw a full, life-size re-creation of the Oval Office using the same materials as the original, Eco wrote, "Is this the taste of America? Certainly it is not the taste of Frank Lloyd Wright, of the Seagram Building, of the skyscrapers of Mies van der Rohe. But the American imagination demands the real thing, and to attain it must fabricate the absolute fake."
意大利作家翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco）几年前写过一篇文章，认为这种创造微型模拟世界的冲动是一种典型的美国式冲动，是一种重要的美国美学，但却很少被谈论。埃科走访了美国各地，从迪士尼乐园到拉斯维加斯，再到博物馆里重现的老纽约。在参观了德克萨斯州奥斯汀的约翰逊图书馆后，他看到那里用与原件相同的材料建造了一个全尺寸的椭圆形办公室模型，埃科写道：“这就是美国的品味吗？当然，这绝非弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）、西格拉姆大厦或密斯·凡·德·罗（Mies van der Rohe）摩天大楼的品味。但美国人的想象力需要真实的东西，为了获得真实，必须制造出绝对的假货。”
On today's program, Act One, a quick national tour. Act Two, writer Jack Hitt on simulated dinosaur worlds. Act Three, we get Medieval on you. Well, we take a Medieval scholar from the University of Chicago-- a guy with an actual British accent, so you can tell he's for real-- with us to Medieval Times, a suburban castle cum restaurant cum jousting arena. Act Four, how Morning Edition fakes reality every day on the radio and why we fall for it. Stay with us.
在今天的节目中，第一幕，一次快速的全国巡回。第二幕，作家杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）讲述模拟恐龙世界。第三幕，带你进入中世纪。嗯，我们带了一位芝加哥大学的中世纪学者——一个有着地道英国口音，所以你能看出他是正宗的——去往中世纪时代（Medieval Times），那是一个集郊区城堡、餐厅和比武场于一体的地方。第四幕，广播里的《早间版》（Morning Edition）是如何每天伪造现实以及为什么我们会被欺骗。请收听。
Act One, Travels in Hyperreality.
第一幕，超真实旅行。
Now, back to Jesus. The following description is alleged to be derived from an ancient manuscript sent by Publius Lentulus, president of Judea, to the Senate of Rome. It reads, "There lives at this time in Judea a man of singular virtue whose name is Jesus."
现在，回到耶稣的话题。以下描述据称源自犹地亚省长普布利乌斯·伦图卢斯（Publius Lentulus）寄给罗马参议院的一份古代手稿。文中写道：“此时在犹地亚住着一位有独特美德的人，他的名字叫耶稣。”
Where are we? A wax museum in San Francisco in front of 13 life-size wax statues recreating Leonardo da Vinci's painting, The Last Supper . In this act of our program, rather than use the Michelin guide to tour America, we're using Umberto Eco's essay, "Travels in Hyperreality." And in researching that essay, Eco visited no fewer than seven-- that's right, seven-- wax versions of The Last Supper between San Francisco and Los Angeles.
我们在哪儿？在旧金山的蜡像馆，面前是13座真人大小的蜡像，重现了列奥纳多·达·芬奇的画作《最后的晚餐》。在节目的这一部分，我们不是用《米其林指南》来游览美国，而是用翁贝托·埃科的文章《超真实旅行》。在研究那篇文章时，埃科在旧金山和洛杉矶之间参观了不少于七个——没错，七个——版本的蜡像《最后的晚餐》。
Eco was fascinated with American wax museums, partly because he said that unlike wax museum in other countries, he says, "American wax museums try to reconstruct entire worlds with a kind of maniacal, chilling attention to detail." This museum, for example, runs 85 different soundtracks in its different rooms. There are scenes of wax figures bathing waist deep in real pools of water. There's a full-scale reconstruction of King Tut's tomb. There are three-dimensional life-size wax versions of a dozen of the world's most famous paintings. A typical exhibit in the World Religion section of the museum, Moses receiving the Ten Commandments on a rocky slope, eerie red light with flashes of white lightning.
埃科对美国的蜡像馆很着迷，部分原因是他认为，与其他国家的蜡像馆不同，他说：“美国的蜡像馆试图用一种近乎疯狂、令人毛骨悚然的细节关注度来重建整个世界。”例如，这个博物馆在不同的房间里播放85种不同的原声带。有蜡像半身浸泡在真实水池里的场景。还有一个图坦卡蒙墓的全尺寸重建模型。还有十几幅世界名画的真人大小三维蜡像版本。博物馆世界宗教区的一个典型展品是摩西在岩石斜坡上接受十诫，配有白色闪电闪烁的诡异红光。
[THUNDER]
[雷声]
I am the Lord your God who brought you out of the land of Egypt, out of the house of bondage. You shall have no other god before me."
“我是主你的上帝，曾将你从埃及地，从为奴之家领出来。除我以外，你不可有别的神。”
Eco had a name for these over-the-top production values. He called it "reconstructive neurosis."
埃科给这种过度夸张的制作价值起了一个名字。他称之为“重构神经症”。
My name is Rodney Fong. I'm actually the grandson of the gentleman who opened this museum in 1963. That's my grandfather Thomas Fong.
我叫罗德尼·方（Rodney Fong）。实际上我是1963年开设这家博物馆的那位先生的孙子。那是我的祖父托马斯·方（Thomas Fong）。
Rodney's family owns the largest wax museum in North America, which is in Los Angeles, and the second largest, which is this museum at Fisherman's Wharf. His family owned three wax museums visited by Umberto Eco when Umberto Eco wrote his essay. Rodney himself is an easygoing, friendly sort who grew up working in the museum's shop after school, now 30 years old and the general manager of the place.
罗德尼的家族拥有北美最大的蜡像馆（位于洛杉矶）和第二大的（即位于渔人码头的这家博物馆）。他的家族拥有翁贝托·埃科在撰写文章时参观过的三家蜡像馆。罗德尼本人是一个随和、友善的人，放学后在博物馆商店工作长大，现在30岁，是这家博物馆的总经理。
And you might think that growing up in a wax museum would be kind of a fun thing for a kid. But he said that was not his experience.
你可能认为在一个蜡像馆里长大对孩子来说是一件很有趣的事。但他表示并非如此。
Actually, I was terrified to go into the museum because my father always used the museum as a threat. If we were not good, we'd have to spend a night in the Chamber of Horrors. So actually to this day, I still get the heebie jeebies walking through by myself.
事实上，我以前很怕进博物馆，因为我父亲总是用博物馆来威胁我。如果我们不听话，就得在恐怖屋里待上一晚。所以直到今天，我独自走过时仍然会感到毛骨悚然。
Rodney tells me we have to rush through the museum because there is so much to see. Over 300 statues, historical figures like Neil Armstrong and Geronimo, right next to fictional characters like Don Quixote and Alice in Wonderland. The juxtaposition is actually kind of dizzying. And Umberto Eco talks about this odd feeling you get in a place like this as "a spatial, temporal haze, where centuries get confused." One room, for example, depicts a dozen people at an outdoor cafe.
罗德尼告诉我，我们要快点穿过博物馆，因为要看的东西太多了。超过300尊雕像，历史人物如尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和杰罗尼莫，旁边就是虚构人物如堂吉诃德和爱丽丝梦游仙境。这种并置实际上让人有些眩晕。翁贝托·埃科谈到在这样的地方你会产生一种奇怪的感觉，即“一种空间和时间上的迷雾，世纪在这里变得混乱”。例如，一个房间描绘了户外咖啡馆里的十几个人。
Mark Twain--
马克·吐温——
Smoking a pipe, looking very stern.
抽着烟斗，表情非常严肃。
Rembrandt, Caruso, Andy Warhol--
伦勃朗、卡鲁索、安迪·沃霍尔——
In a leather jacket.
穿着皮夹克。
Whistler, Beethoven, Toulouse-Lautrec. Who else is down here?
惠斯勒、贝多芬、图卢兹-劳特累克。这儿还有谁？
Hemingway's off by himself. And Mozart, Beethoven, and Whistler are sitting at a table together. And there's a can of Campbell's tomato soup on there. And you get the feeling that Andy Warhol reached over--
海明威独自在一边。莫扎特、贝多芬和惠斯勒坐在一张桌子旁。桌上有一罐金宝番茄汤。你会觉得安迪·沃霍尔伸手过来——
Right. And put that on there.
对。把它放在那里。
Umberto Eco writes, "When you see Tom Sawyer immediately after Mozart, or you enter the cave of the Planet of the Apes after having just witnessed the Sermon on the Mount with Jesus and the Apostles, the logical distinction between real world and possible worlds has been definitively undermined."
翁贝托·埃科写道：“当你看到莫扎特之后紧接着是汤姆·索亚，或者在刚目睹了耶稣与使徒的登山宝训后进入《人猿星球》的洞穴时，现实世界与可能世界之间的逻辑区分就已经被彻底削弱了。”
There is something so strange about combining figures from different historical moments together.
将不同历史时期的数字结合在一起确实有些奇怪。
Really, part of that is because of space. I mean, we keep adding figures year after year. We have to start categorizing them and putting them together.
实际上，这部分是因为空间问题。我的意思是，我们年复一年地增加人物。我们必须开始对它们进行分类并把它们放在一起。
Eco says that one reason Americans have an urge to build elaborate wax museums, to reenact the Civil War, to construct full-size, fake Colonial towns, is that we just don't have as strong a sense of history as Europeans have. And so it's like we're seeking to ground ourselves in some vivid sense of history. And these are the tools that we use.
埃科说，美国人之所以有一种建造复杂蜡像馆、重演内战、建造全尺寸假殖民地城镇的冲动，原因在于我们不像欧洲人那样有强烈的历史感。所以这就像我们试图在某种生动的历史感中找到立足点。而这些就是我们使用的工具。
Rodney and I turn a corner, and we see this combination of historical figures. Albert Einstein, Sigmund Freud, Charles Darwin, Galileo, and Bill Gates, in a sweater, holding a copy of Windows 95. That's just down the hallway from a room called "Wickedest Ladies," where the plaques read, "Jezebel, biblical siren," "Salome, biblical siren," "Lucrezia Borgia, siren of the Renaissance," and then there's Mata Hari, who, for some reason, is a dead ringer-- I'm not kidding-- for Barbra Streisand.
罗德尼和我转过一个拐角，看到了这些历史人物的组合：阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦、西格蒙德·弗洛伊德、查尔斯·达尔文、伽利略，还有穿着毛衣、拿着一本《Windows 95》手册的比尔·盖茨。就在走廊下面，有一个叫“最邪恶的女士”的房间，牌子上写着：“耶洗别，圣经中的海妖”，“莎乐美，圣经中的海妖”，“卢克雷齐娅·博尔贾，文艺复兴时期的海妖”，还有一个玛塔·哈里，不知为何，她——我没开玩笑——和芭芭拉·史翠珊长得一模一样。
There's also a room with figures that are very mysteriously grouped. They are Boy George, Lawrence Welk, Danny Thomas, John Travolta. What is the theme of this room, OK? Performers you suspect are gay? Scientologists? Has-beens? Rodney has no answers. He takes me to stand in front of a room with just one lone figure, wielding a gun. Chuck Norris.
还有一个房间里的数字分组非常神秘。那是乔治男孩、劳伦斯·威尔克、丹尼·托马斯、约翰·特拉沃尔塔。这个房间的主题是什么？你怀疑是同性恋的表演者？科学教徒？过气明星？罗德尼没有答案。他带我站在一个只有一尊挥舞着枪的人物面前。查克·诺里斯（Chuck Norris）。
Now, why is it that Chuck Norris gets his own room and Nelson Mandela has to share a room with four other people?
现在，为什么查克·诺里斯能有自己的房间，而纳尔逊·曼德拉却不得不和其他四个人共用一个房间？
If we had other action figures, they'd be in this room also.
如果我们有其他的动作明星，他们也会在这个房间里。
But for now, Chuck Norris not only gets his own room, he gets a full movie set. That's what it's like. There's a beach with a blown-up car and pieces all around him plus that semiautomatic weapon. The point of all this obsessively reconstructed detail, Umberto Eco says, is partly to reassure people that no expense has been spared. "This," he says, "is what Americans want. An insane abundance, like at those supposedly classy American restaurants, all darkness and wood paneling, dotted with soft red lights that offer the customer, as evidence of his own affluence, steaks four inches thick and lobster and baked potato and sour cream and melted butter and grilled tomato and horseradish sauce, so that the customer will have more and more and can wish nothing further."
但目前，查克·诺里斯不仅拥有自己的房间，还拥有一个完整的电影布景。就是这样。那里有一个海滩，有一辆炸毁的汽车，周围是碎片，再加上那把半自动武器。翁贝托·埃科说，所有这些强迫性的重建细节的部分目的是为了让人们放心，没有节省任何费用。他说：“这就是美国人想要的。一种疯狂的丰富，就像那些所谓的高档美国餐厅，全是黑暗和木镶板，点缀着柔和的红灯，以彰显顾客自己的富裕，提供四英寸厚的牛排、龙虾、烤土豆、酸奶油、融化的黄油、烤番茄和辣根酱，这样顾客就会拥有越来越多，也就别无所求了。”
The logical outcome of this desire is places like the Madonna Inn, a hotel in California that Eco describes this way. "The poor words with which human natural speech is provided can not suffice to describe the Madonna Inn. Let us say that Albert Speer, while leafing through a book on Goudy swallowed an over-generous dose of LSD, and began to build a nuptial catacomb for Liza Minnelli. But that doesn't give you an idea. Let's say Arcimboldi builds the Sagrada Familia for Dolly Parton. Or Carmen Miranda designs a Tiffany locale for the Jolly Hotel chain. Calvino's Invisible Cities described by Judith Krantz and executed by Leonor Fini for the plush-doll industry. Chopin's Sonata in B flat minor sung by Perry Como in an arrangement by Liberace accompanied by the Marine Band No, that still isn't right.
这种欲望的逻辑结果就是像麦当娜旅馆（Madonna Inn）这样的地方，加利福尼亚的一家酒店，埃科这样描述它：“人类自然语言中贫乏的词汇不足以形容麦当娜旅馆。让我们说，阿尔伯特·斯佩尔在翻阅一本关于高迪的书时，吞下了一剂过量的LSD，开始为丽莎·明尼利用地建造一座婚姻地下墓穴。但这并不能让你有个概念。让我们说阿钦波尔多为多莉·帕顿建造了圣家堂。或者卡门·米兰达为欢乐酒店连锁店设计了一处蒂芙尼风格的地方。卡尔维诺的《看不见的城市》由朱迪思·克兰茨描述，并由莱奥诺·菲尼为毛绒玩具行业执行。肖邦的《降B小调奏鸣曲》由佩里·科莫演唱，利伯拉切编曲，海军军乐队伴奏……不，那也不对。”
"Let's try talking about the restrooms. They are an immense underground cavern, something like Altamira and Luray, with Byzantine columns supporting plaster baroque cherubs. The basins are big imitation mother-of-pearl shells. The urinal is a fireplace carved from the rock, but when the jet of urine-- sorry, but I do have to explain here-- touches the bottom, water comes down from the wall of the hood in a flushing cascade, something like the caves of the Planet Mongo.
“让我们试试谈谈洗手间。它们是一个巨大的地下洞穴，有点像阿尔塔米拉和卢雷，有拜占庭式的柱子支撑着石膏巴洛克小天使。脸盆是巨大的仿珍珠母贝壳。小便池是一个从岩石中雕刻出来的壁炉，但当你排尿时——抱歉，但我确实必须在这里解释一下——当尿流触碰到底部时，水会从罩檐的墙壁上如冲洗瀑布般倾泻而下，有点像《人猿星球》里的洞穴。”
"Then there are the bedrooms, about 200 of them, each with a different theme. For a reasonable price-- which includes an enormous bed, king or queen size if you are on your honeymoon-- you can have the Prehistoric Room, all cavern and stalactites, the Safari Room, zebra walls and bed shaped like a Bantu idol, the Kona Rock Room, Hawaiian, the California Poppy, the Old-Fashioned Honeymoon, the Irish Hills, the William Tell, the Tall and Short, for mates of different lengths, with the bed in an irregular polygon form. There's the Imperial Family, there's the Old Mill.
“还有卧室，大约200间，每间都有不同的主题。价格合理——包括一张巨大的床，如果你是度蜜月的话，king或queen size——你可以选择史前房间，全都是洞穴和钟乳石；野生动物园房间，斑马纹墙壁，床是班图偶像形状；科纳摇滚房间，夏威夷风格；加州罂粟花；老式蜜月；爱尔兰山；威廉·泰尔；高矮房间，适合不同身高的伴侣，床呈不规则多边形。还有帝国家庭房间，老磨坊房间。”
"The Madonna Inn is the poor man's Hearst castle. It has no artistic or philological pretensions. It appeals to the savage taste for the amazing, the overstuffed, and the absolute sumptuous. At a low price, it says to its visitors, 'You can have the incredible, just like a millionaire.'"
“麦当娜旅馆是穷人的赫氏城堡。它没有艺术或文献学的野心。它迎合了对惊人、填充物和绝对奢华的野蛮口味。以低廉的价格，它告诉游客：‘你可以像百万富翁一样拥有不可思议的东西。’”
[COAL MINE SOUNDS]
[煤矿声音]
OK, OK, OK. We've changed scene. Maybe you've figured that out. Now we're in a coal mine, a fake coal mine. In fact, we're faking being in a fake coal mine. That's just how fake this is. I'm just sitting in a radio studio playing you a tape. You know, simulated worlds actually are so abundant, within a half-hour drive of where I sit right now here in Chicago, where we broadcast our radio show from, right now, I can jump in the car and visit-- OK, I'm just going to list quickly-- a re-creation of an Al Capone speakeasy, a Medieval castle, a 3-D IMAX movie theater which attempts to recreate three-dimensionality, a store called Nike Town, which essentially puts you into the world of a Nike commercial.
好了，好了，好了。我们换个场景。也许你已经发现了。现在我们在一个煤矿里，一个假煤矿。事实上，我们在假装身处一个假煤矿。这就是它有多假。我只是坐在广播室里给你播放录音。你知道，模拟世界确实非常丰富，从我现在广播节目的芝加哥所在地开车半小时内，我可以跳上车去参观——好吧，我就快速列举一下——阿尔·卡彭地下酒吧的重现、中世纪城堡、试图重现三维感的3D IMAX电影院、一家叫Nike Town的商店，它基本上把你带入了耐克广告的世界。
And at the Museum of Science and Industry, a fake human heart big enough to walk through, an actual 727 airplane, an entire airplane inside the museum, a real German U-boat captured during World War II, and, built directly into the museum, a fake coal mine.
在科学与工业博物馆里，有一个大到可以走进去的假人心，一架真正的波音727飞机，博物馆里整整一架飞机，二战中俘获的真实德国U型潜艇，以及直接建在博物馆里的假煤矿。
Now, the first bell will indicate that we are arriving, and the second bell will indicate that we have arrived. Please feel free to touch the coal. It has been laminated, therefore it isn't harmful to you or your clothing.
“现在，第一个铃声表示我们将到达，第二个铃声表示我们已经到达。请随意触摸煤炭。它经过了层压处理，所以对你或你的衣服无害。”
A couple years ago, historian Frances FitzGerald wrote this book called Cities on a Hill , where she argued that one of the defining qualities of America is the number of people here who try to shed the past, completely shed it, start over tabula rasa, and create a new way of life for themselves, in new communities unlike communities that had existed before. From the survivalists in Montana to the gay community in San Francisco to the Mormons in Utah. Looked at in this way, creating new worlds is what this country is. It is what we do.
几年前，历史学家弗朗西斯·菲茨杰拉德（Frances FitzGerald）写了一本名为《山上的城市》（Cities on a Hill）的书，她在书中认为，美国的一个决定性品质是这里有很多人试图抛弃过去，彻底抛弃它，一切从零开始，重塑生活方式，在与以前社区不同的新社区中生活。从蒙大拿州的生存主义者到旧金山的同性恋社区，再到犹他州的摩门教徒。从这个角度来看，创造新世界就是这个国家的样子。这就是我们所做的。
And so when we create these little small, simulated worlds for recreation, wax museums and Medieval castles and technicolor movies, for that matter, we're just doing in miniature, for recreation, what we do for real, as a whole, in our culture.
所以，当我们为了娱乐而创造这些小型的模拟世界——蜡像馆、中世纪城堡和彩色电影时，我们只是在微缩的娱乐层面上做我们在整个文化中真实要做的事情。
Act Two, Dinosaur Exhibit. Well, all this hour, we're talking about simulated realities, simulated worlds, wax museums, Civil War reenactments, fake coal mines. You know, one thing you can say about all those worlds is that anybody can tell that they're fake. When you go to a wax museum, when you go to the Luxor Hotel in Las Vegas, this huge pyramid with a full-scale replica of the Sphinx out in front, you do not stand there and wonder, "Did I wake up this morning in Cairo?" You know where you are.
第二幕，恐龙展览。嗯，这一小时我们都在谈论模拟现实、模拟世界、蜡像馆、内战重演、假煤矿。你知道，关于所有这些世界，有一点你可以肯定，那就是任何人都能看出它们是假的。当你去蜡像馆，当你去拉斯维加斯的卢克索酒店（那个巨大的金字塔，前面还有斯芬克斯的全尺寸复制品）时，你不会站在那里想：“我今天早上是在开罗醒来的吗？”你知道你在哪里。
The world of dinosaurs presents a different problem, and that's because of the veneer of science. When you go to a natural history museum and you see a dinosaur exhibit, the impression that you get is that what you're seeing is not conjecture, not theory, but settled, scientific fact. But as our contributing editor Jack Hitt recently discovered, the world of the dinosaurs turns out to be a man-made world made up of a pile of bones. And like most other things that are man-made, our picture of the dinosaurs has been flawed and imperfect. And it changes.
恐龙世界提出了一个不同的问题，这是因为科学的掩盖。当你去自然历史博物馆看到恐龙展览时，你会得到一种印象：你所看到的不是推测，不是理论，而是已定的科学事实。但正如我们的特约编辑杰克·希特最近发现的那样，恐龙世界原来是一个由一堆骨头构成的、人为制造的世界。而且像大多数其他人造事物一样，我们对恐龙的认识也是有缺陷和不完美的。而且它在不断变化。
Not long ago, I attended a lecture by dinosaur revisionist Jack Horner. He's a notorious troublemaker, a hippie without a formal degree who turns dinosaur thinking upside-down. He's a tall, skinny thing in jeans and boots, tangled gray hair and a generous beard. Horner's speech was entitled, "Would Tyrannosaurus Rex Eat a Lawyer?" The reference, of course, is that scene in Jurassic Park when the lawyer gets yanked right off the john by an enraged T. rex.
不久前，我参加了恐龙修正主义者杰克·霍纳（Jack Horner）的讲座。他是一个臭名昭著的麻烦制造者，一个没有正规学位的嬉皮士，颠覆了恐龙思维。他个子高，瘦削，穿着牛仔裤和靴子，灰白的头发纠结，留着大胡子。霍纳的演讲题目是《霸王龙会吃掉律师吗？》。引用当然来自《侏罗纪公园》中那个律师被愤怒的霸王龙直接从厕所拽出来的场景。
Naturally, we all thought the answer to his semi-rhetorical question was, sure. Of course. T. rex could eat a lawyer anytime, anyplace. But Horner was there to prove that T. rex could only have eaten the lawyer if the lawyer were already dead. T. rex, he said, was not a mighty, roaring predator, not king of the dinosaurs, not Godzilla, but a slow, putzy scavenger who wandered from carcass to carcass half-blind, snacking on rotting scraps.
自然，我们都认为他那个半反问问题的答案是：当然。霸王龙当然随时随地都能吃掉律师。但霍纳出现在那里是为了证明，只有在律师已经死了的情况下，霸王龙才可能吃掉他。他说，霸王龙不是强大的、咆哮的捕食者，不是恐龙之王，不是哥斯拉，而是一个半盲的、缓慢的食腐动物，从一具尸体游荡到另一具尸体，啃食腐烂的残骸。
No one in the room quite wanted to believe it. Little kids just sat silent in incredulous awe, as if he had said that sharks only ate plankton. But Horner piled on the logic. Typically, predators, he said, like lions and tigers, have powerful front arms to hold their catch while they rip out the jugular. T. rex has no arms, really. Just those dainty claw-ettes, comparable to having a few fingers growing out of your shoulders. Interesting, but not exactly threatening.
屋里没有人真的想相信这一点。小孩子们只是沉默地坐着，带着难以置信的敬畏，就好像他说鲨鱼只吃浮游生物一样。但霍纳堆砌了逻辑。他说，通常捕食者，如狮子和老虎，有强大的前肢来抓住猎物，同时撕裂它们的颈动脉。霸王龙真的没有手臂。只有那些娇小的爪子，相当于肩膀上长了几根手指。有趣，但算不上威胁。
T. rex also had big, muscular legs, usually interpreted to mean he could run fast. But Horner asked, how swift are weight lifters? In nature, sprinters tend to have long calves and short thighs for leverage, like ostriches. Animals with stout, muscular legs tend to be walkers, typically slow, usually not too coordinated. Horner was making sense. There were lots of shifting of chairs and coughing.
霸王龙还有粗壮的肌肉腿，通常被解读为它能跑得很快。但霍纳问，举重运动员有多敏捷？在自然界中，短跑运动员往往有长小腿和短大腿以获得杠杆作用，比如鸵鸟。腿部粗壮、肌肉发达的动物往往是步行者，通常很慢，通常协调性也不是太好。霍纳说得通。椅子发出很多移动的声音，伴随着咳嗽声。
And then there was more. CAT scans of T. rex skulls have revealed a sense of smell more elaborate than any other species except the turkey vulture, a handy adaptation if you're pursuing stinking corpses. Also, his eyesight was poor, not good for predators, who tend to hunt at twilight. At last, Horner said, T. rex didn't even walk the way every book and National Geographic magazine and Spielberg movie has shown us, standing up, constantly roaring, front claws poised to strike. No, instead, he walked about like a sandpiper, a bird, head down, tail straight out, body parallel to the ground, but with all the agility of a penguin.
还有更多。对霸王龙颅骨的CAT扫描揭示了一种比土耳其秃鹰以外的任何物种都更复杂的嗅觉，如果你是在追踪腐烂的尸体，这是一个方便的适应。此外，它的视力很差，这对捕食者来说不是好事，因为它们往往在黄昏狩猎。最后，霍纳说，霸王龙甚至走路的方式都不像每一本书、每一本《国家地理》杂志和每一部斯皮尔伯格电影向我们展示的那样——站立着，不断咆哮，前爪准备出击。不，相反，它像鹬鸟一样走路，头向下，尾巴直伸，身体与地面平行，但敏捷度也就跟企鹅差不多。
It was a strange feeling in that room, as we all experienced a kind of reverse epiphany, when something you are absolutely certain to be true turns out to be completely false. But you know, once you hear the evidence, it just seems obvious. I mean, those tiny claws. Come on. Weren't they always a tip off?
那个房间里有一种奇怪的感觉，我们都经历了一种反向的顿悟，当你绝对确定是真的事情竟然完全是假的。但你知道，一旦你听到了证据，它看起来就显而易见。我是说，那些细小的爪子。得了吧。它们难道不一直是个暗示吗？
But after a while, I no longer cared about the new T. rex as much as I wanted to know where that older figment, the marauding predator, had come from. We invented him, of course, constructed him from just a few bones. But why? From his office in Montana, Horner told me that the old T. rex was, in part, the creation of a kind of arms race.
但过了一会儿，我不再关心新霸王龙了，而是更想知道那个旧的幻影——那个掠夺性捕食者是从哪儿来的。当然是我们发明的，用几块骨头拼凑出来的。但为什么？在蒙大拿州的办公室里，霍纳告诉我，旧的霸王龙在某种程度上是一种军备竞赛的产物。
Cope and Marsh. It was a competition.
科普（Cope）和马什（Marsh）。那是一场竞争。
Edward Cope and O. C. Marsh, the two Indiana Joneses of the turn of the century. Cope was associated with the University of Pennsylvania, Marsh with Yale. They were called the bone warriors. Two men who hated each other's guts, and every year pursued larger pots of money to fund more elaborate excursions, to find even bigger bones.
爱德华·科普和O.C.马什，世纪之交的两位印第安纳·琼斯。科普与宾夕法尼亚大学有关，马什与耶鲁大学有关。他们被称为“骨头勇士”。两个互相痛恨对方的人，每年都在追逐更大的资金池，以资助更精细的考察，寻找更大的骨头。
It was during the time of P. T. Barnum. It was during the time when you put up your most fantastic stuff in your museum or your circus or whatever it is you happen to have. And you draw people in. And you're competing with everyone else.
那是在P.T.巴纳姆（P.T. Barnum）的时代。那是一个你把最奇妙的东西放在博物馆或马戏团或任何你拥有的地方的时代。你吸引人们进来。而且你在和所有人竞争。
So a lot of T. rex's original persona came not from science but just good old American hucksterism. That's why they forced T. rex to stand unnaturally upright, on his hind legs. Although there was one other reason.
所以霸王龙最初的许多人格不是来自科学，而只是老派的美国骗术。这就是为什么他们强迫霸王龙不自然地直立，用后腿站立。尽管还有另一个原因。
It's because people made dinosaur halls with very high ceilings, and they had to fill up that extra space with something. But I mean it's hard to tell what it was. I mean, they wanted these animals to look ferocious, so they made them as tall as possible.
这是因为人们建造恐龙大厅时天花板非常高，他们不得不填补额外的空间。但我很难说那是什么。我是说，他们想让这些动物看起来凶猛，所以他们把它们做得尽可能高。
And to make it as tall as possible, they had to bend the tale of T. rex, and worse.
为了让它尽可能高，他们不得不弯曲霸王龙的尾巴，甚至更糟。
They broke skeletons. They removed parts. It's funny. I mean, early on, they actually found evidence that animals didn't drag their tails. But in some cases, they actually removed the evidence so they could get the tail on the floor.
他们弄断了骨架。他们移除了部分。这很有趣。我是说，早些时候，他们确实发现了动物不拖着尾巴走路的证据。但在某些情况下，他们实际上移除了证据，以便让尾巴垂在地上。
Does it get any more rigged than that? But it isn't just that most of what we thought we knew about dinosaurs was wrong. It turns out that in the century or so since dinosaurs entered human consciousness, they've passed through discernible fashions, changing, not as often as skirts or haircuts, but at a slower pace, like men's lapels, about every 10 to 15 years. They've served as a kind of national psychic Erector Set, which we've put together in different ways depending on our mood.
还有比这更操纵的吗？但这不仅仅是关于恐龙的大多数认识是错误的。事实证明，在恐龙进入人类意识的近一个世纪里，它们经历了可辨识的时尚，发生了变化——不像裙子或发型那样频繁，但以较慢的节奏，就像男士的翻领一样，大约每10到15年一次。它们一直作为一种国民心理的组合玩具，我们根据心情以不同的方式组装它们。
To compile a comprehensive list of dinosaur fashions, I drove back to the first great hall of dinosaurs, New York's Museum of Natural History. Earlier this year, they assembled their dinosaur bones into a new, more so-called "accurate" display. Appropriately enough, before the visitor even gets to see the new exhibit, one has to walk through a tall chamber housing the old standards, the twin icons of dinosaur myth.
为了编制一份恐龙时尚的综合清单，我开车回到了第一个伟大的恐龙大厅——纽约自然历史博物馆。今年早些时候，他们将恐龙骨架组装成了一个新的、所谓的“准确”展示。恰如其分地，在参观者还没看到新展品之前，就必须走过一个高大的大厅，里面安置着旧标准——恐龙神话的孪生偶像。
It was good to see them again. Here was T. rex, head bowed in his new humble position. And across the aisle with his long, gracious neck and frisky, five-ton tail was the old friendly Brontosaurus. I know he has some new name, but I can never remember what it is. Anyway, Brontosaurus and T. rex stand in a room all by themselves these days, obsolete models parked next door to the hipper, newer displays. In other words, dinosaurs of dinosaurs.
很高兴再次见到它们。这就是霸王龙，头部低垂在它新的卑微位置。而在过道对面，有着优雅的长脖子和五吨重的活泼尾巴的，是那只老朋友雷龙。我知道它有个新名字，但我永远记不住是什么。总之，雷龙和霸王龙现在独自待在一个房间里， obsolete（过时）的模型停在更酷、更新的展品隔壁。换句话说，恐龙的恐龙。
I was shown around by Philip Fraley, a mounting expert. He's the man who does the actual work of making these bones assume the positions they do. We sat beneath the rear end of the Brontosaurus. Philip tried to take me back to the first decade of the century, when even seeing a dinosaur meant getting on a train and coming to one of the few museums that Cope or Marsh had stocked. Given Fraley's occupation, he wanted me to appreciate something else.
我是由装架专家菲利普·弗雷利（Philip Fraley）带领参观的。他就是负责让这些骨头呈现出它们姿态的实际工作者。我们坐在雷龙的后部下面。菲利普试图带我回到世纪的第一个十年，当时即使是看一只恐龙也意味着要坐火车去科普或马什存放骨头的少数博物馆之一。考虑到弗雷利的职业，他希望我欣赏别的东西。
The beauty of the armature itself.
装架本身的美。
By armature, Philip means the steel frame that holds the bones up. And I did come to appreciate its beauty.
菲利普说的装架是指支撑骨头的钢架。我也确实开始欣赏它的美了。
T-joints and unions, and they've been threaded. Our pelvis weighs 2,000 pounds. So to lift that up and to have 2,000 pounds supported on inch-and-a-half pieces of steel requires a lot of engineering. The tensile strength of the steel, the cantilever weight--
T型接头和联合处，它们都被旋上了螺纹。我们的骨盆重2000磅。所以要把那个抬起来，让2000磅支撑在1.5英寸的钢材上，需要大量的工程设计。钢的抗拉强度，悬臂重量——
This was high tech for its time. These creatures had slept forever, and now they were upright for the first time in 100 million years. What had put them back on their feet, literally, was the wrought-iron strength of Pittsburgh steel, the American Industrial Revolution. But the exact dates are also timely. The Brontosaurus went up in 1906 and the T. rex in 1912, just before World War I, when the slumbering giant of America awoke.
这对当时来说是高科技。这些生物沉睡了永远，现在它们是1亿年来第一次直立起来。字面上把它们重新站立起来的，是匹兹堡钢铁的锻铁强度，美国的工业革命。但确切的日期也很及时。雷龙在1906年竖立，霸王龙在1912年，就在第一次世界大战前夕，当时美国这个沉睡的巨人觉醒了。
To the Europeans, we were still a friendly, dumb rube of Tocqueville's Democracy in America. But we were about to prove ourselves as international warriors. The crowds that flooded through New York's museum saw two images, the affable but dim Brontosaurus, and across the aisle, the berserker rage of T. rex, friendly until agitated, then fury, which is how the world came to see us, an amiable, joshing hick who, if provoked, will kick your ass.
对欧洲人来说，我们仍然是托克维尔《论美国的民主》中那个友好、愚蠢的乡巴佬。但我们即将证明自己是国际战士。涌入纽约博物馆的人群看到了两个形象：随和但迟钝的雷龙，以及过道对面霸王龙的狂战士怒火，友好直到被激怒，然后是狂暴——这就是世界看待我们的方式：一个和蔼可亲、爱开玩笑的乡巴佬，如果被激怒，就会踢你的屁股。
By World War II, T. rex had become important enough to our nation that, incredibly, there were contingency plans to protect the skeleton the same way we protect the president and the original copy of the Constitution.
到了二战，霸王龙对我们国家来说已经变得足够重要，令人难以置信的是，当时的应急计划保护这具骨架的方式，就跟我们保护总统和《宪法》原件一样。
The country felt there was a likelihood that the museum could come under attack by the German Army or the German Navy. And in order to preserve the specimens, they contacted the Carnegie Museum in Pittsburgh.
国家认为博物馆很可能遭到德国陆军或海军的攻击。为了保护这些标本，他们联系了匹兹堡的卡内基博物馆。
So T. rex was shipped off to Pittsburgh, presumably where the Germans would never go. By the '50s and '60s, technology forever changed the dinosaur, and we came into post-war dinosaur fashion. Where the beast once was made from the T-joints of Bessemer steel, a new substance gave him an improved flexibility.
所以霸王龙被运往了匹兹堡，大概是德国人永远不会去的地方。到了50和60年代，技术永远改变了恐龙，我们进入了战后的恐龙时尚。曾经由贝塞麦钢T型接头制成的野兽，现在一种新物质赋予了它改进的灵活性。
Plastics.
塑料。
That's right, Benjamin. Plastics. Now any museum could have a perfect reproduction of New York's or Yale's bones. A plaster cast could be reproduced endlessly. But this took interpretation out of the hands of paleontologists and put it directly in the hands of museum curators.
没错，本杰明。塑料。现在任何博物馆都可以拥有纽约或耶鲁骨骼的完美复制品。石膏模型可以无休止地复制。但这将解释权从古生物学家手中夺走，直接交到了博物馆馆长手中。
What they allowed people to do was to put them into some outrageous poses.
他们允许人们做的是把它们放在一些离谱的姿势里。
So now dinosaurs could be jimmied into action poses, locked into face to face combat like two upright grizzly bears or reared back ready to assault. This was the '50s dinosaur, the dinosaur of kitsch. They were no longer held up by steel but animated by plastic, the essence of America at that time, a substance and a future entirely of our own making.
所以现在恐龙可以被扭进动作姿势，像两只直立的灰熊一样锁定在面对面的战斗中，或者后仰准备攻击。这就是50年代的恐龙，媚俗的恐龙。它们不再由钢铁支撑，而是由塑料动画化，那正是当时美国的本质——一种完全由我们自己创造的物质和未来。
These plasticized dinosaurs continued until the cutthroat '80s, the decade of Michael Milken. In this era, no longer was the dinosaur a big, dim monster. Now he was a sleek, swift, calculating hunter, the Velociraptor, a six-foot tall predatory entrepreneur who learned and adapted quickly. He was the perfect dinosaur for global capitalism, who'd eventually star in a bestselling book and movie, Jurassic Park.
这些塑料化恐龙一直持续到残酷的80年代，那个迈克尔·米尔肯的年代。在这个时代，恐龙不再是一个巨大、迟钝的怪物。现在它是圆滑、敏捷、精于算计的猎手，迅猛龙，一个六英尺高的掠夺性企业家，学习和适应得很快。它是全球资本主义的完美恐龙，最终主演了一本畅销书和电影《侏罗纪公园》。
They're lethal at eight months. And I do mean lethal.
它们在八个月大时就致命。我是说真的致命。
Do they show intelligence?
它们表现出智慧吗？
Even problem-solving intelligence. When she looks at you, you can see she's working things out. They remember.
甚至是解决问题的智慧。当她看着你时，你能看出她在思考。它们记得。
T. rex is so strange in that movie. He comes across like the elderly member of the family. His big scene is when he eats the lawyer. But T. rex is clearly second banana to our new star. His appearance is like Robert Mitchum's cameo in the updated Cape Fear , a wink at the audience from the grizzled original.
霸王龙在那部电影里真是奇怪。它给人的感觉就像家里年迈的成员。它的大戏是吃掉那个律师。但霸王龙显然是二号人物。它的出现就像罗伯特·米彻姆（Robert Mitchum）在更新版《恐怖角》（Cape Fear）中的客串，是来自饱经风霜的原始版本对观众的一瞥。
[DINOSAUR ROARING]
[恐龙咆哮]
Now, the '90s dinosaur. Philip and I walked into the new dino display, where T. rex and the Brontosaurus hardly seem relevant. We see dinosaur eggs and baby dinosaurs. The ambiance is largely about parenting. The scenes are more ecological and holistic. We are meant to see these animals as part of the natural ecosystem of their time, eggs, babies, parents, death, bones. This is a story about the cycles of life, a warmer tale, a greener tale. This is a story of dinosaurs not as George Patton would see them, but as Al Gore would, emblems of a proper view of the environment. The Eco-saur, who's seen the light of family values and the beauty of biodiversity.
现在，90年代的恐龙。菲利普和我走进新的恐龙展区，霸王龙和雷龙似乎几乎无关紧要了。我们看到恐龙蛋和恐龙宝宝。氛围主要围绕育儿。场景更具生态性和整体性。我们被要求将这些动物视为它们时代自然生态系统的一部分：蛋、宝宝、父母、死亡、骨骼。这是一个关于生命循环的故事，一个更温暖的故事，一个更环保的故事。这不是巴顿将军眼中的恐龙，而是戈尔眼中的恐龙，是环境正确观点的象征。这种生态恐龙已经看到了家庭价值观和生物多样性之美。
And in an era when America's role in the world is uncertain, when solutions to many of its problems are unclear, our nation's dinosaur exhibits speak directly to our time in bright yellow stickers attached directly to the display cases. That message, "We just don't know."
在一个美国在世界上的作用不确定、许多问题解决方案尚不明确的时代，我们国家的恐龙展览用直接贴在展示柜上的亮黄色标签直接与我们这个时代对话。那个信息是：“我们就是不知道。”
Like, look at this one right here. Look at this sign. There's a big yellow sign. And it says, "These are all intriguing hypotheses, but the fossils do not give us enough evidence to test whether any of them are correct. The mystery remains unresolved."
比如，看看这个。看看这个标志。有个大大的黄色标志。它写着：“这些都是有趣的假说，但化石没有给我们提供足够的证据来测试它们中任何一个是否正确。谜团依然未解。”
Well, right. I mean, I think that what we're saying is believe what you want to believe.
嗯，对。我是说，我想我们想说的是，相信你想相信的吧。
Still, after you've passed by every display, it's possible to sense a coherent thesis among the hedging plaques and timid explanations. I honestly couldn't put my finger on it at first, but Philip did.
不过，在你经过每一个展台后，在回避的牌子和胆怯的解释中，还是可能感觉到一个连贯的论点。老实说，我起初无法明确指出它，但菲利普做到了。
Dinosaurs were the most successful life form that ever lived on this planet, and they became extinct. And extinction is a real part of life. And it's not so bad.
恐龙是这颗星球上曾经存在过的最成功的生命形式，它们灭绝了。灭绝是生命中真实的一部分。这没那么糟糕。
Well, sure, if you're a fungus or a bug. You know, it was only 100 years ago that dinosaurs signaled the beginning of American greatness. What progress we've made.
好吧，当然，如果你是一个真菌或虫子的话。你知道，就在100年前，恐龙还标志着美国伟大的开始。我们取得了多大的进步啊。
When the dinosaurs died out, the world went on and other species were created. One of those species happened to be the human form. I think that in all likelihood, our species one day will become extinct. And when that happens, that's probably not a bad thing.
当恐龙灭绝时，世界继续运转，其他物种被创造出来。其中一个物种恰好是人类。我想很有可能，我们的物种有一天也会灭绝。而当那一刻发生时，那大概不是件坏事。
I'm reminded of a Gary Larson cartoon. An auditorium of dinosaurs are assembled. They're seated in their chairs, their long necks and little pin heads looking quizzically at the dinosaur speaking on the stage. He's showing a big map of the world, poking at it with a pointer. And he's saying, "Folks, the news is bad. Another ice age is coming, food is growing scarce, and we've got brains the size of walnuts."
我想起了加里·拉尔森（Gary Larson）的一幅漫画。一个恐龙礼堂里集合了恐龙。它们坐在椅子上，长长的脖子和细小的针头脑袋疑惑地看着舞台上的恐龙发言。它展示了一张巨大的世界地图，用指针戳着。它说：“各位，消息很糟糕。另一个冰河时代即将来临，食物越来越少，而且我们的大脑只有核桃那么大。”
[MUSIC - "I'M A LITTLE DINOSAUR" BY JONATHAN RICHMAN]
[音乐 - 乔纳森·里奇曼（Jonathan Richman）的《我是个小恐龙》]
Jonathan Richman. And before that, Jack Hitt, a This American Life contributing editor and a writer who lives in New Haven. Well, coming up, we go back in time only 900 years with another simulated world. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
乔纳森·里奇曼。在那之前是杰克·希特，一位《美国生活》特约编辑和住在纽黑文的作家。好吧，接下来，我们将回到900年前的另一个模拟世界。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's show, Simulated Worlds. And we have arrived at Act Three of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会在节目中选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，《模拟世界》。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
I'm just going to describe where we are. We're heading out on Interstate 90 here, just north of Chicago, towards the northwest suburbs. And it's just basically your basic industrial parks. There's a building called Intergraph.
我来描述一下我们在哪里。我们正沿着90号州际公路向北行驶，就在芝加哥以北，朝西北郊区前进。那里基本上就是普通的工业园区。有一栋叫Intergraph的建筑。
But we're looking for the Middle Ages. We're on a  quest for Medieval authenticity, because we're going to Medieval Times.
但我们在寻找中世纪。我们正在进行一场寻求中世纪真实性的冒险，因为我们要去“中世纪时代”。
Medieval Times is a chain of seven fake castles across the United States. For about $35 per person, you get a jousting tournament and Medieval dinner. Drinks, commemorative photos, and a trip to the dungeon cost extra. To judge the authenticity and meaning of the experience, I asked Michael Camille to come with me. He's a Medieval scholar at the University of Chicago. And he's actually made it his hobby to visit Medieval re-creations and tourist sites wherever he can find them. He had never been to Medieval Times before, but he had been to several re-creations of the Middle Ages in Europe, where they do them in real castles.
“中世纪时代”是美国境内七个假城堡组成的连锁店。每人大约35美元，你可以观看比武锦标赛和中世纪晚餐。饮料、纪念照片和参观地牢需额外付费。为了评判这种体验的真实性和意义，我请迈克尔·卡米尔（Michael Camille）和我一起去。他是芝加哥大学的中世纪学者。他的爱好是参观他能找到的所有中世纪重现和旅游景点。他以前从没去过“中世纪时代”，但他去过欧洲的几个中世纪重现点，那里的重现是在真正的城堡里进行的。
There's one called the Canterbury Pilgrims' Way in Canterbury in England, where you literally go into a space where everything, the sound and even the smell of the Middle Ages, is supposedly re-created. They say, see the sights, smell the smells. So you smell the farmyard where the peasants are milking the cows.
英国坎特伯雷有一个叫“坎特伯雷朝圣者之路”的地方，你实际上走进了一个空间，那里的一切，甚至中世纪的声音和气味，据说是重现出来的。他们说，看景色，闻气味。所以你能闻到农民正在挤牛奶的农场气味。
And they had wax figures?
他们有蜡像吗？
And they had waxwork figures for the individual.
他们有个人蜡像。
And did they smell?
它们有味道吗？
They smelled.
它们有味道。
They smelled. The wax figures smelled.
它们有味道。蜡像有味道。
Michael says he notices an upsurge in interest in the Middle Ages, in Medieval fairs, in Medieval re-creations. He thinks it's because most people see the Middle Ages as a time when life was orderly and simple, when knights were knights and peasants were peasants and people knew where they stood. Or that's what people think anyway.
迈克尔说他注意到人们对中世纪的兴趣激增，在中世纪集市、中世纪重现中。他认为这是因为大多数人将中世纪视为一个生活有序、简单，骑士就是骑士，农民就是农民，人们各安其位的时代。或者无论如何人们是这么认为的。
Then there are the people who are attracted to the Gothic horror of the period, gargoyles, dungeons.
还有那些被那个时期的哥特式恐怖、滴水嘴、地牢所吸引的人。
It's the same thing. It's finding an ideal. Except the ideal's exactly the opposite. It's disorder, not order. It's monstrosity, not pageantry.
是一回事。是在寻找一种理想。除了那个理想恰恰相反。那是混乱，不是秩序。那是畸形，不是盛况。
Do you think that the impulse that draws people to a place like Medieval Times and to places like Medieval fairs, do you believe that that impulse that pulls people towards those things is similar to the impulse that makes you a historian of this period?
你认为吸引人们去“中世纪时代”这类地方以及像中世纪集市这类地方的冲动，你相信那种把人们拉向这些事物的冲动，类似于让你成为这个时期历史学家的冲动吗？
People have different reasons for the time traveling-- is what we're doing now. Some people time travel now to really enter another world and to escape, ultimately. For our great-grandparents who liked Medieval things, I think it seemed very safe, the Middle Ages. If you were religious, it was a nice, sacred time. If you were interested in chivalry, it was a chivalric time and concepts of honor were crucial.
人们进行这种时间旅行（我们现在所做的事情）有不同的原因。有些人进行时间旅行是为了真正进入另一个世界并最终逃避。对于那些喜欢中世纪事物的我们的曾祖父母来说，我想中世纪看起来非常安全。如果你信仰宗教，那是一个美好的、神圣的时代。如果你对骑士精神感兴趣，那是一个骑士时代，荣誉概念至关重要。
My interest, I suppose, is more-- I see it as a time of enormous other-ness to us today. I think of it as incredibly different from today. And it's that difference that excites me. It was a world in which you could get married when you were 12 years old, and when you could be burned at the stake for thinking certain things. I mean, it's a world of such difference. That's what fascinates me.
我想我的兴趣更多是——我将其视为一个对我们今天来说极度“他者”的时代。我认为它与今天截然不同。正是那种差异让我兴奋。那是一个你可以在12岁时结婚，并且可以因为思考某些事情而被烧死在火刑柱上的世界。我的意思是，那是一个如此不同的世界。这就是让我着迷的地方。
See, I wonder, in fact, if they're going to emphasize an other-ness, or if we'll feel any other-ness, or if everything will be--
看，实际上我很好奇，他们是会强调一种他者性，还是我们会感觉到任何他者性，或者一切都会是——
Well, that's the interesting-- let's see. That will be interesting.
嗯，那很有趣——让我们看看。那会很有趣。
We continue driving past industrial parks and suburban sprawl until finally, just past the corporate campus of one of the most high-tech companies in America, Motorola, Michael and This American Life producer, Nancy Updike, and I see the sign. Medieval Times, next right.
我们继续经过工业园区和郊区扩张，直到最后，就在美国最高科技公司之一摩托罗拉的企业园区后面，迈克尔、《美国生活》制作人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我看到了那个标志。“中世纪时代”，下一个路口右转。
OK, now keep your eyes peeled. See the flags over there? I bet they're underneath-- do you see it?
好了，现在睁大眼睛。看到那边的旗帜了吗？我敢打赌它们就在——你看到了吗？
Oh, my goodness. There it is. It's a wonderful-- look at the marvelous crenulation, with three flags, the American flag-- I can't see, it's too far away to see what other flag. And of course, that, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] have a problem. The American flag flying over a Medieval castle.
哦，我的天。在那里。真美——看看那个精妙的齿垛，有三面旗帜，美国国旗——我看不清，太远了，看不出是什么别的旗帜。当然，那个，[听不清]有个问题。美国国旗飘扬在中世纪城堡上。
A 14th-century castle, Michael says. A late 14th-century castle combined with a McDonald's. Picture, if you will, a low, square, industrial warehouse with turrets and castle towers stuck on here and there. As we pull up closer, we see that the whole building is made of this kind of plastic-y cement with lines carved on it to imitate stones. Michael marvels at what he keeps calling the heraldry, the huge, multi-colored shields hanging high on the wall facing the parking lot. They are authentic, he says. In the parking lot, we encounter an unpleasant smell, but we are unable to determine if it is authentic Middle Ages or not. And then--
14世纪的城堡，迈克尔说。一个14世纪后期的城堡和麦当劳结合在一起。请想象一下，如果你愿意的话，一个低矮、方形的工业仓库，到处插着角楼和城堡塔楼。当我们靠近时，我们发现整座建筑都是由那种塑料水泥制成的，上面刻着纹路来模仿石头。迈克尔对他一直称之为“纹章”的东西感到惊奇，巨大的、五颜六色的盾牌悬挂在面对停车场的墙壁高处。他说它们是真实的。在停车场，我们遇到了一股令人不快的味道，但我们无法确定这是不是正宗的中世纪气息。然后——
If you would, proceed through the doorway. You should be meeting with the royal couple, His Grace the Count and the Lady Contessa.
“如果你愿意的话，请穿过门口。你应该会见到皇室夫妇，伯爵殿下和女伯爵阁下。”
We're barely in the door and people in bright, velvety costumes are count and contessa-ing us. And we're quickly ushered before a man in a crown and a cape who looks a lot like the post-James Bond pre- Rising Sun Sean Connery and a woman in a glittery princess dress. It's not really the costumes that get to you in Medieval Times. Walking around, you realize the sheer power of language. Everyone is calling you m'lord and m'lady and it is hard to know how to respond. Everyone in our little group gets very awkward. For some reason, I find that I stop using contractions, as if no one around me speaks English as a first language.
我们刚进门，穿着明亮天鹅绒服装的人就在对我们行伯爵和女伯爵礼。我们很快被带到一位戴着皇冠、披着斗篷的男士面前，他看起来很像后詹姆斯·邦德、前《升阳》时期的肖恩·康纳利，旁边是一位穿着闪亮公主裙的女士。在“中世纪时代”，让你印象深刻的并不是服装。走来走去，你会意识到语言的绝对力量。每个人都称呼你为“阁下”和“夫人”，很难知道该如何回应。我们小群体里的每个人都变得非常尴尬。出于某种原因，我发现自己停止使用缩略语，就好像周围没人把英语作为第一语言一样。
We do not understand that. We can not all go together.
我们不理解那个。我们不能都一起走。
Nancy, meanwhile, completely freaks out. I'm going to play you this piece of tape. And what you need to know is that when it starts, she's sticking a big boom microphone in the count's face.
与此同时，南希彻底崩溃了。我要给你播放这段录音。你需要知道的是，当它开始时，她正把一支大吊杆麦克风伸到伯爵的脸上。
I'm not familiar with that term, "radio." What is that? She's pointing a strange weapon at us, m'lady. I know not what that is. It's some kind of a mace, I believe.
我对“广播”这个词不熟悉。那是什么？她在用一种奇怪的武器指着我们，夫人。我不知道那是什么。我相信那是某种权杖。
All of a sudden, without warning, she bows.
突然之间，没有任何预警，她鞠了一躬。
We mean you no harm.
我们对你没有恶意。
Oh, is that right? Thank you. I am glad to hear that.
哦，是吗？谢谢。很高兴听到这个。
Our photo is taken with the royals. Those photos are for sale later in the evening. And we are each handed a black-and-white paper crown. Everyone acts like there is no question whether or not we will, in fact, where these crowns.
我们和皇室成员拍了照。那些照片稍后在晚上出售。我们每个人都被分发了一顶黑白纸皇冠。每个人都表现得好像是否要戴上这些皇冠根本不成问题。
Tonight you shall be cheering for the holy and pious warrior priest, the black and white knight. Your mortal enemy for this evening's tournament is the red and yellow knight.
“今晚你们将为神圣而虔诚的战士牧师、黑白骑士欢呼。今晚比赛中你的死敌是红黄骑士。”
Michael, our Medieval scholar, is loving this. And I mean, loving it. He loves how they try to get the audience involved in the experience. He loves the fact that everyone is divided into six different teams, each rooting for a different region of Spain, each rooting for a different knight. He loves the fact that we were introduced to the lords of this castle.
我们的中世纪学者迈克尔对此乐在其中。我是说，非常喜欢。他喜欢他们试图让观众参与体验的方式。他喜欢每个人被分成六个不同的团队，每支队伍支持西班牙的一个不同地区，支持一个不同的骑士。他喜欢我们被介绍给这座城堡的主人。
This is just wonderful. This is so much more exciting than I imagined. This is a really wonderful experience.
这太美妙了。这比我想象的还要令人兴奋。这真是一次美妙的体验。
Well, what are you seeing that you're liking so far?
嗯，你目前看到了什么你喜欢的？
Well, I think that's very nice to be welcomed by the lord and lady of the castle. Hospitality was a crucial aspect of the Medieval tournament.
嗯，我认为受到城堡主人的欢迎是非常好的。热情好客是中世纪锦标赛的关键环节。
Really?
真的吗？
Its whole point was you were being hospitable. You were bringing people into your-- and giving them a little largesse.
它的全部意义就在于热情好客。你是在邀请人们进入你的——并给予他们一点慷慨。
Because we're here as members of the media, we're soon taken aside to be greeted by the real lord of this particular castle. His name is Leslie Davies and he is not wearing a velvet cape, but rather a well-cut, expensive looking, dark blue suit.
因为我们是以媒体成员的身份来到这里的，所以我们很快被带到一边，去见这座城堡的真正主人。他的名字叫莱斯利·戴维斯（Leslie Davies），他没有穿天鹅绒斗篷，而是穿着一套剪裁合体、看起来很昂贵的深蓝色西装。
I'm the man that cuts that fish. In other words, I sign the paychecks. So yes, I am the lord.
我就是那个切鱼的人。换句话说，我是签支票的人。所以是的，我是领主。
Mr. Davies is the general manager here. He says that Medieval Times started in Spain. Its owners are Spanish. And so the tournament we're about to see is a re-creation of a Spanish-style tournament in the year 1093. He says the main difference between the two European castles owned by the firm and the seven in the States is that the crowds in the United States are less inhibited when they root for their knights. It is, by his account, a very profitable little kingdom they run.
戴维斯先生是这里的总经理。他说“中世纪时代”起源于西班牙。它的所有者是西班牙人。所以我们要看的比赛是1093年西班牙式锦标赛的重现。他说，该公司拥有的两个欧洲城堡和美国的七个城堡之间的主要区别在于，在美国，观众在为他们的骑士欢呼时比较放得开。根据他的说法，他们经营的这片小王国利润非常丰厚。
How much does one of these buildings cost you to put up?
建造这些建筑之一要花费多少钱？
Between $15 and $20 million.
在1500万到2000万美元之间。
How many people do you serve here a year?
你们一年在这里接待多少人？
About 300,000.
大约30万。
Marketing manager Steve Davidson pipes in.
营销经理史蒂夫·戴维森（Steve Davidson）插话说。
That's 300,000 appetizers, 300,000 bowls of soup, 300,000 chickens, 600,000 glasses of Pepsi. It's rather involved.
那是30万份开胃菜，30万碗汤，30万只鸡，60万杯百事可乐。这相当复杂。
Now, to get a perspective on exactly what these numbers mean, I think we actually have to leave the scene in the castle for a moment. Let me get this sound out of here. OK, there. And now, well, let's do the numbers.
现在，为了准确理解这些数字的含义，我想我们实际上必须暂时离开城堡场景。让我把这段声音弄走。好了，在那儿。现在，好吧，让我们算算这些数字。
Medieval Times in Chicago serves 300,000 people a year. 300,000 is also the size of the audience of Chicago's public radio station, where I work. Now let us consider staff size. Size of National Public Radio's entire network news division, that's all of Morning Edition all of All Things Considered all of National Public Radio's reporters all over the globe is 195 people. Medieval Times has 250 full-time employees at this one castle. Remember there are six others in addition. Medieval Times has an annual budget that is millions of dollars larger than National Public Radio.
芝加哥的“中世纪时代”每年服务30万人。30万也是我工作的芝加哥公共广播电台的听众规模。现在让我们看看员工规模。美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）整个网络新闻部门的规模——也就是所有的《早间版》、《万事皆考量》、NPR遍布全球的所有记者，总共是195人。“中世纪时代”在这个城堡就有250名全职员工。记住还有其他六个城堡。 “中世纪时代”的年度预算比NPR多出数百万美元。
And all of this data may not mean all that much to you. But from where I sit, I feel that it forces me to this disturbing conclusion. And that is that I work for a radio network that is less popular than jousting, a sport that has been dead for 400 years.
所有这些数据对你来说可能意义不大。但从我坐的地方来看，我觉得这迫使我得出这个令人不安的结论。那就是，我效力的广播网络竟然比一项已经消失了400年的运动——比武竞技——更不受欢迎。
All the way around, please, to the very last green section.
请一直转到最后一个绿色区域。
The audience now files into an arena that seats around 1,400. It looks like a medium-sized professional hockey rink, partly because they have those Plexiglas screens around the edges of the oval to protect you, to divide you from the performers who are down there in the center. Instead of ice, of course, in the center there's sand. And the tiered seats that rise up steeply on all sides of this oval have tables in front of them for dinner. And the seats are color-coded. Everyone rooting for our knight, the black and white knight, sits together in a group. Michael notices the music.
观众现在进入一个大约可容纳1400人的竞技场。它看起来像一个中等规模的专业曲棍球场，部分原因在于它们在椭圆形边缘周围有那些有机玻璃屏幕来保护你，把你和竞技场中心的表演者隔开。当然，中心没有冰，而是沙子。在这个椭圆形的四面陡峭升起的阶梯式座位前有餐桌供用餐。座位是按颜色编码的。所有支持我们骑士——黑白骑士的人坐在一起。迈克尔注意到了音乐。
As these people are processing in, we have Gregorian chant religious music, beautiful, piped, liturgical music going on in the background. Which is very strange at a tournament.
当这些人进入时，背景里有格里高利圣咏宗教音乐，美丽的、播放的、礼仪音乐。这在锦标赛中非常奇怪。
Strange and inaccurate?
奇怪且不准确？
But again, I don't like using that word, "inaccurate." You can't measure an experience like this through accuracy, because I just don't think that's the right criteria to say this isn't right, because I think it's how it feels.
但再说一次，我不喜欢用“不准确”这个词。你不能用准确性来衡量这样的体验，因为我不认为那是说它“不对”的正确标准，因为我认为重要的是它感觉如何。
But that doesn't feel quite right to you?
但这让你感觉不对劲吗？
The priest might do a blessing, or something. But you're not going to have monks singing part of the holy liturgy before a tournament.
牧师可能会做个祈祷之类的。但在锦标赛前你不会有僧侣在唱圣礼仪的一部分。
It turns out the entire evening is scored with music. It's like a movie. During the horse exhibition section of the evening, there's a kind of disco, horsey music. Nancy swears she heard Carmen at one point during the evening. But most of the music sounds like the soundtrack of a movie whose images and values, when you get right down to it, come straight from the Middle Ages.
事实证明，整个晚上都配有音乐。就像电影一样。在晚上的马匹表演部分，有一种迪斯科式的马术音乐。南希发誓她在晚上某个时刻听到了《卡门》。但大多数音乐听起来像是一部电影的原声带，如果你深究的话，它的形象和价值观直接来自中世纪。
[TRUMPET FANFARE]
[小号号角]
Doesn't this sound like the theme to Star Wars?
这听起来不像《星球大战》的主题曲吗？
Good evening, my lords and lady, and welcome to Medieval Times. My name is Jim and I'll be your serf tonight.
“晚上好，阁下和夫人，欢迎来到‘中世纪时代’。我叫吉姆，今晚我将担任你们的农奴。”
Jim brings us each a Medieval appetizer, a kind of faux pizza, a Medieval roasted chicken, which is conveniently pre-sliced-- which is important because we're given no silverware and have to tear it apart with our hands-- and our Medieval Pepsis. Nancy and Michael find the food hateful, but I kind of like it.
吉姆给我们每个人带来了一份中世纪开胃菜，一种仿披萨，一份中世纪烤鸡，它们被方便地预先切片了——这很重要，因为我们没有餐具，必须用手撕着吃——还有我们的中世纪百事可乐。南希和迈克尔觉得食物很难吃，但我倒是有点喜欢。
Are you a wench.
你是女仆吗。
Yes, I am a wench.
是的，我是女仆。
Are you a drinks wench, or a--
你是饮料女仆，还是——
I am a photo wench.
我是照片女仆。
We're informed that "wench" is an actual job title here, that it's on the application. We wonder if people put it on their resumes once they've worked here. Cocktail wenches, server wenches.
我们被告知“女仆”在这里是一个实际的职位头衔，申请表上就有。我们想知道人们一旦在这里工作过，是否会把它写在简历上。鸡尾酒女仆，服务女仆。
Michael says the whole wench thing, the whole idea of it, is just complete bunk. In the real Middle Ages, women actually never served food to nobles, who were the only people who attended tournaments like this. And in fact, even the word "wench" did not exist until much, much later.
迈克尔说关于女仆的一切，整个想法，完全是胡扯。在中世纪真实历史上，女性从未给贵族服务过食物，而贵族是唯一参加这类锦标赛的人。事实上，“wench”这个词直到很久很久以后才出现。
So "wench" is-- you know, "ye olde wench," is a modern construction. That's a construction that's something to do with London pubs of the 18th century. It's not to do with the Middle Ages.
所以“wench”是——你知道，“老式女仆”是一种现代构建。那是一种与18世纪伦敦酒馆有关的构建。它与中世纪无关。
Soon, another anachronism. All the serfs and wenches traipse out into the central arena.
不久，又一个时代错误出现了。所有的农奴和女仆都蹒跚走进中央竞技场。
My lords and ladies, show your appreciation for your hard-working serfs and wenches.
“阁下和夫人，请表达你们对辛勤工作的农奴和女仆的赞赏。”
Oh. The serfs and wenches are out now. But you see, you'd never have serfs and wenches out on the tournament field.
哦。农奴和女仆现在出来了。但是你看，你永远不会在锦标赛场地看到农奴和女仆。
Because they're too lowly?
因为他们地位太低？
They're too lowly. They're absolutely lowly.
他们地位太低。他们绝对地位卑微。
But this is America after all, where any serf or wench can grow up to be president. And so it is no surprise that commoners end up on the playing field with the nobles. And it is the nobles who star in the show. Six knights and six squires, all of them with long hair and fake chain-mail that gives them a look that's part Middle Ages and part Jon Bon Jovi. They start by doing these complicated dressage demonstrations with their horses. They have these beautiful Andalusian stallions. And the horses have been trained to side step and bow and weave in and out in complicated patterns.
但毕竟这里是美国，任何农奴或女仆都可以成长为总统。所以平民最终出现在竞技场与贵族在一起也就不足为奇了。而且是贵族主演了这场演出。六名骑士和六名侍从，都留着长发，穿着假锁子甲，让他们看起来既有一部分中世纪的味道，又有一部分乔恩·邦·乔维（Jon Bon Jovi）的影子。他们首先用他们的马进行这些复杂的盛装舞步表演。他们有这些美丽的安达卢西亚种马。马匹被训练成侧步、鞠躬，并以复杂的图案穿梭往来。
The knights then do these various kinds of target practice on horseback. The capture flags, they hit bullseyes, they spear tiny brass rings with their lances. None of this, Michael says, would have been part of a real Medieval tournament. This would be practice, practice stuff you do beforehand.
然后骑士们在马背上进行各种打靶练习。他们捕捉旗帜，击中靶心，用长矛刺中微小的黄铜环。迈克尔说，这些都不会是真实中世纪锦标赛的一部分。这会是练习，是你事先做的练习。
Then the arena begins to fill with smoke. Fog machines pump out so much mist you cannot see the floor. There's eerie purple light and a hooded figure with a lantern.
然后竞技场开始充满烟雾。雾机喷出大量的薄雾，你无法看清地板。有诡异的紫光和一个提着灯笼的连帽身影。
Oh, no. No, in the arena. This does not bode well, Your Grace. I shall summon forth your court sorcerer at once. Through this mist walks Lord [? Gallenon ?], high priest of the Druids.
哦，不。不，在竞技场里。这可不是个好兆头，殿下。我立刻召唤你的宫廷巫师。在这迷雾中走出来的是领主[？Gallenon？]，德鲁伊的大祭司。
High priest of the Jews? Did he say high priest of the Jews?
犹太人的大祭司？他说的是犹太人的大祭司吗？
The Druid. The Druid. Druid. Now, this is a funny mixture. There were no Druids in 1119, Spain.
德鲁伊。德鲁伊。德鲁伊。现在，这是一个有趣的混合。1119年的西班牙没有德鲁伊。
The Druids were in England. And they vanished 600 years before tournaments like this. They built Stonehenge. This was the one moment at Medieval Times when Michael seemed truly disappointed.
德鲁伊在英国。而且他们在锦标赛这类活动出现前600年就消失了。他们建造了巨石阵。这是在“中世纪时代”迈克尔看起来真正失望的一个时刻。
I think they're trying to evoke Mer-- why didn't they use Merlin, or something. Like, Merlin the magician, that would be more apt. So it's to bring in a feeling of magic. I suppose this is a New Age-y bit of it.
我想他们是想唤起梅——为什么他们不使用梅林之类的。比如，魔法师梅林，那会更贴切。所以是为了带来一种魔法感。我想这是其中新时代的一点。
After this, there are more impressive horse maneuvers. We're told that we're supposed to boo every time the green knight appears. The green knight is set up as the evil knight in this pageant. Michael says that particular color choice is not the best. He says that in the Middle Ages, green was the color of goodness, it was the color of godliness. Think Sir Gawain and the Green Knight. Black, he says, would have been a more accurate color to represent an evil knight in the Middle Ages, but black representing evil probably would not fly in multicultural, modern America. Finally, target practice is finished, and the main event's about to begin. Jousting.
在此之后，还有更多令人印象深刻的马术动作。我们被告知每次绿骑士出现时我们都要嘘他。绿骑士在这个盛会中被设定为邪恶的骑士。迈克尔说那个特定的颜色选择不是最好的。他说在中世纪，绿色是善良的颜色，是虔诚的颜色。想想《高文爵士与绿骑士》。他说，黑色会是一个更准确的代表中世纪邪恶骑士的颜色，但黑色代表邪恶在多元文化的现代美国可能行不通。最后，打靶练习结束，重头戏即将开始。比武竞技。
You're holding a couch lance. That's the lance that you're holding under your right shoulder. And the whole point in the joust itself is to unhorse your opponent.
你拿着一支练习矛。那是你拿在右肩下的长矛。比武本身的全点就是要让你的对手下马。
So wait a second. These guys are going to charge against each other? I mean, it's just occurred to me, the reality of what's going to happen here. They're going to charge at each other and try to hit each other off of a horse with a big stick?
等等。这些人要互相冲锋吗？我的意思是，这里将要发生的现实刚才才出现在我脑海里。他们要互相冲锋，试图用一根大棍子把对方从马上撞下来？
That's what a joust is.
那就是比武竞技。
How can you survive that?
你怎么能在那场活动中生存？
Women and girls in the audience give handkerchiefs to the various knights to carry into battle, a historically correct moment that Michael likes a lot. And then the jousting begins. Over the course of the evening, we've learned next to no facts or history about the Middle Ages. But Medieval Times does stage a great fight. It's complicated. It's cinematic. As I said earlier, there's music through everything that happens on this arena. It's totally choreographed. It lasts a long time. And it involves no fewer than 14 people and six horses.
观众中的女性和女孩把手帕交给不同的骑士带入战斗，这是一个迈克尔非常喜欢的历史正确时刻。然后比武开始了。在整个晚上，我们几乎没学到关于中世纪的事实或历史。但“中世纪时代”确实上演了一场伟大的战斗。它很复杂。它很电影化。正如我之前所说，在这个竞技场上发生的一切都有音乐伴随。它是完全编排好的。它持续了很长时间。它涉及不少于14人和6匹马。
Green knocked yellow off the horse. Now the green guy is coming at him with a-- ooh! What is that?
绿色把黄色撞下了马。现在那个人正拿着一个——噢！那是什么？
That's a mace.
那是权杖。
It's a ball on a chain on a stick.
它是一根棍子上系着一条链子连着一个球。
Ooh, that's--
噢，那是——
And now the yellow guy is staggering around, holding a knife.
现在那个人正摇摇晃晃地走着，拿着一把刀。
Green knight. Hold. Stand fast. You have lost your weapon and therefore lost the honor of horseback. I say dismount and continue the fight on foot.
绿骑士。停止。站住。你丢失了武器，因此失去了马上的荣誉。我命令你下马，在地面上继续战斗。
So the green-- the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] knight is getting down now.
所以那个绿骑士现在正下来。
Now, wait. Now, would that happen in a real tournament? They'd tell the guy to get off the horse?
现在，等等。那会在真正的锦标赛中发生吗？他们会叫那个人下马吗？
Yes. Because often tournaments would-- in fact, this is a misconception about knights. Even when knights went into battle in the battlefield, they got off their horses to fight. The English became the great warriors of the late Middle Ages by getting off their horses just like this and fighting on the ground. Because you couldn't do much on a horse. You could do the lance thing, but you couldn't kill someone up close.
是的。因为锦标赛通常会——事实上，这是一个关于骑士的误解。即使骑士在战场上战斗时，他们也会下马战斗。英国人通过像这样下马在地面上战斗，成为了中世纪后期的伟大勇士。因为你在马上做不了什么。你可以做长矛的事情，但你无法近距离杀死某人。
By the end of the evening, everybody's been killed except for the evil green knight, who gets sent to the dungeon and one other knight, our knight, the black and white knight. Later, we were told the whole thing's fixed. And they put us on the black and white team, because they knew he was going to win. Michael points out that the whole idea that these knights would try to kill each other is not historically accurate. Most tournaments were not intended as a fight to the finish. But despite this, he liked Medieval Times. In the car on the way home, he said that it was Medieval in spirit, anyway. It was spectacle, it was circus, it was populace, it was lowbrow in the best possible sense.
到了晚上结束时，除了邪恶的绿骑士被送进地牢外，每个人都被杀死了，还有另一位骑士，我们的黑白骑士。后来，我们被告知整件事是安排好的。他们把我们安排在黑白队，因为他们知道他会赢。迈克尔指出，这些骑士会试图互相杀死的想法在历史上并不准确。大多数锦标赛并不是为了分出胜负的战斗。但尽管如此，他还是喜欢“中世纪时代”。在回家的车上，他说无论如何，它在精神上是中世纪的。它是奇观，是马戏，是大众的，它是最好意义上的低俗。
There were hundreds of things in there I could have said were inaccurate, inauthentic, in terms of costume, design, action. But I think that's the wrong way to think about it. If that was an accurate representation of a Medieval tournament, people would be bored stiff. They wouldn't go to it. They wouldn't get anybody to it, because they lasted for six days. And they were like conventions of aristocrats. It wasn't the kind of experience that is going to be entertaining to people. So if they were being truly authentic, it would be very boring for us.
里面有数百件事我可以说是由于服装、设计、动作方面的不准确、不真实。但我认为那是错误的思考方式。如果那是中世纪锦标赛的准确呈现，人们会感到无聊透顶。他们不会去的。他们无法吸引任何人去，因为它们持续了六天。它们就像贵族大会。那不是一种会让人们觉得有趣的体验。所以如果他们真的追求绝对真实，那对我们来说会非常无聊。
When we driving out to Medieval Times earlier, Michael had said that the thing that appealed to him most about the Middle Ages was this other-ness, the fact that it did not seem like our world at all. And in the car home, I suggested to him that Medieval Times did not create that feeling at all. It was mostly familiar images from movies and storybooks. But he disagreed.
当我们之前开车去“中世纪时代”时，迈克尔说他最被中世纪吸引的是这种“他者性”，即它看起来一点也不像我们的世界这一事实。在回家的车上，我向他暗示“中世纪时代”根本没有创造出那种感觉。它主要是电影和故事书中熟悉的形象。但他不同意。
It was weird enough in all the mixtures of strange things in it. I mean, the odd mixture of the modern building and the castle's structure and the long-haired hunky knights that looked like centerfolds from Playgirl with the ways that the things were mixed together. To me, in a strange way, it was Medieval. Because obviously, the Middle Ages is incredibly hybrid and confused. And again, that's what attracts me about it. It's certainly not the age of order and systematic piety that everyone thinks.
它在其中奇怪事物的混合中足够怪异。我的意思是，现代建筑、城堡结构、留着长发的健壮骑士（看起来像《花花公子》的插页）与事物混合在一起的方式。对我来说，在某种奇怪的方式上，它是中世纪的。因为显然，中世纪是极其混合和混乱的。再一次，这就是吸引我关于它的地方。它肯定不是每个人认为的那个秩序和系统虔诚的时代。
But the strangeness that you're describing is not the strangeness of the Middle Ages. It's the strangeness of America.
但你描述的那种奇怪并不是中世纪的奇怪。那是美国的奇怪。
Exactly.
正是如此。
Exactly, Michael said. In fact, as far as he's concerned, America is a very Medieval country, far more Medieval than Western Europe.
正是如此，迈克尔说。事实上，在他看来，美国是一个非常中世纪的国家，远比西欧更中世纪。
In the Middle Ages, it was a pioneer culture. They were just beginning to create things. There was a sense of newness moving forward, evangelical, full of weird and wonderful mixtures, ultra-religious, and yet at the same time, ultra-decadent. I think that's one of the reasons why we're so fascinated in America with the Middle Ages. Because we're living it.
在中世纪，那是一种先驱文化。他们刚开始创造东西。有一种向前推进的新鲜感，福音派的，充满了奇怪而美妙的混合，极度宗教，但同时又极度颓废。我想这就是为什么我们对中世纪如此着迷的原因之一。因为我们正生活在其中。
In the commemorative photo they took of us at Medieval Times, the distinguished scholar from the University of Chicago is grinning happily, a paper crown on his head. The little mock frame they put the photo inside says in typeface at the bottom, "Your Knight to Remember." That's knight, K-N-I-G-H-T.
在他们在“中世纪时代”为我们拍的纪念照中，那位来自芝加哥大学的杰出学者正在开心地笑着，头上戴着纸皇冠。他们把照片放进去的模拟小框架底部的字体写着：“你记住的骑士”（Your Knight to Remember）。那是骑士，K-N-I-G-H-T。
Act Four, simulated worlds on the radio. I worked for National Public Radio's network headquarters in Washington starting when I was 19 years old, a long time ago. And I would like to talk for a minute about how reality is simulated, is constructed on programs like Morning Edition and All Things Considered , programs I love, programs I worked on.
第四幕，广播里的模拟世界。我从19岁起就在华盛顿的NPR网络总部工作，那是很久以前的事了。我想花一分钟谈谈现实是如何在《早间版》和《万事皆考量》这样的节目中被模拟、被构建的——这些我热爱、我工作过的节目。
Consider Morning Edition . Bob Edwards, the host of the show, says hello and he mentions a few stories coming up today. And then he says, "First, this news from Carl Kasell." Why does he do that? Well, presumably, Carl is closer to reality. He's closer to the truth, he's closer to the thing being simulated in this simulated world on the radio. And then Carl starts in with the first story. Carl says, today in Russia, somebody did whatever.
考虑《早间版》。节目的主持人鲍勃·爱德华兹（Bob Edwards）打招呼，提到今天即将播出的几个故事。然后他说：“首先，这是来自卡尔·卡塞尔（Carl Kasell）的消息。”为什么他要这样做？嗯，大概卡尔离现实更近。他离真相更近，他离这个广播模拟世界中被模拟的事物更近。然后卡尔开始讲第一个故事。卡尔说，今天在俄罗斯，某人做了什么。
And then he hands off to a reporter. And again, why does he hand off to the reporter? Well, presumably, the reporter is closer to reality, to the truth, to the thing being simulated in this simulated world. And then the reporter comes on. And the reporter says, OK, today the Russian president said whatever. And then the reporter goes on, at some point during their story, to some piece of tape that they're going to play us. And that piece of tape is maybe 12 seconds, maybe 14 seconds, 17 seconds long. And it's like one long sentence, or maybe two sentences of somebody, some Russian, saying something about something, right?
然后他转交给记者。再次，为什么他要转交给记者？嗯，大概记者离现实、离真相、离这个模拟世界中被模拟的事物更近。然后记者上场了。记者说，好吧，今天俄罗斯总统说了什么。然后记者继续，在他们的故事中某个时刻，播放一段他们要给我们听的录音。那段录音可能是12秒，可能是14秒，17秒长。它就像一个人的一句长句子，或者两句话，某个俄罗斯人说关于某件事的话，对吧？
And at that point, we're there. We've gone as far as we can go. We are actually at the real. We're hearing a tape recording made out in the world. This is the real. We have arrived. And it's interesting that the word for that piece of tape in radio journalism is the "actuality." Like, it's this precious piece of the actual world on the radio. Like you have this whole apparatus, and then finally you get to what's real. And what's funny about it is how puny it usually is. Like a sentence or two, you know? That's how much reality you get. That's how much actuality you get.
在那一刻，我们到了。我们已经走得尽可能远了。我们实际上是在真实处。我们听到的是在现实世界中制作的录音。这是真实。我们到了。有趣的是，在广播新闻中，那段录音的词汇是“实况”（actuality）。就像它是广播中真实世界的一件珍贵片段。就像你拥有整个装置，然后你最终得到了真实的东西。有趣的是，它通常是多么微小。就像一两句话，你知道吗？这就是你得到的现实。这就是你得到的实况。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Peter Clowney. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Music help today from Stuart Rosenberg.
好吧，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。音乐帮助来自斯图尔特·罗森伯格（Stuart Rosenberg）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
In the years since we first broadcast today's program, Michael Camille, who was that wonderful Medieval scholar from the University of Chicago, who you heard in that last story, a guy, I  have to say, who shocked us all by loving Medieval Times instead of looking down on it, Michael passed away at the age of 44, very, very young. You can read more about him if you want, at our website. The web address is www.thisamericanlife.org.
在我们首次播出今天的节目后的这些年里，迈克尔·卡米尔——那位你刚才听到的故事中来自芝加哥大学的美妙中世纪学者，我要说，那位因喜爱“中世纪时代”而不是看不起它而让我们所有人震惊的家伙——迈克尔在44岁时去世了，非常非常年轻。如果你愿意，可以在我们的网站上阅读更多关于他的信息。网站地址是 www.thisamericanlife.org。
At the website, you can also listen to our programs for free, or, you know, you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even The New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
在网站上，你也可以免费收听我们的节目，或者，你知道，你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在 audible.com。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持致谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他提醒你——
Our species one day will become extinct.
“我们的物种有一天也会灭绝。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。